meaning that functions are inverses of
each other well what it means is that if
you take your initial value you put it
into your function and then you take
that quantity you put it into your
inverse function you get back the
original values it's kind of like if you
take like a number and you multiply it
by seven and then you divide it by seven
you get back that original number
because multiplying and dividing there
are inverse functions right or if you
square something square root or add
subtract those are all inverses of each
other but the way that we test you know
algebraically that functions are
inverses of each other or verify or
prove or show is to use this method here
of composition of functions F of G of X
if you compose these two and you get x
or G of f of X and you get X again all
that saying is is that we know we put in
X we get our output we put it into the
other function and we it takes us back
to the original quantity which was ax
and we want to make sure we do it in
both orders so you want to do it both F
of G of X as well as G of f of X if you
get X for both then you've successfully
proved that the functions are inverses
of each other so let's do some examples
and you'll see how this works so example
number one we've got f of X equals 2x
minus seven so the first thing that I
would just want to show you is how do
you calculate or find the inverse of
this function well f of X you can think
of as y okay Y is like your output but
what you do when you find an inverse is
you switch the X and the y wherever you
see X you put Y wherever you see you
know why you put actually just you
interchange the X and the y then what
you want to do is you want to solve for
the new Y so I'm going to add 7 to both
sides divide everything by 2 and now you
can see we get y equals x plus 7 over 2
now instead of Y I'm going to use this F
inverse notation see that minus 1/2 you
know basically indicate that it's the
inverse of this original function here
okay but now if we want to verify you
know that they're actually inverses say
for example they gave us these two
functions and said are the inverses of
each other what we want to do is we want
to say okay let's let's check F of F
inverse of X so what we're going to do
is we're going to take our inverse
function which is
X plus 7 over 2 we're going to put it
into our half function which is 2 times
X minus 7 so again remember the wave
functions work whatever's in parentheses
goes in place of X on the right side of
the equation so we're just going to
replace X with the new x value the new
input and we're going to simplify now
notice that when you multiply by 2 u
divided by 2 these are inverses they
cancel so we're down to X plus 7 minus 7
7 and negative 7 those cancel we just
get ax so you don't want to just stop
there though we want to also compose it
the other way as well so here we did F F
inverse of X now let's do F inverse f of
X so now we're going to take our f of X
function 2x minus 7 we're going to put
it into our f inverse function and
that's this one here so whatever is in
the parentheses that's going to go in
place of X on the right so we've got 2x
minus 7 I put that in place of X there
plus 7 more right all divided by 2 well
you can see negative 7 and positive 7
those are cancelling 2x divided by 2 the
twos are going to cancel and you're just
left with X so you can see when we
compose it in both orders we got X for
both and you've successfully proved or
verified that those functions are
inverses